[Laughter]
when we first looked up to the stars we
couldn't help but imagine what might
live there yet so far we have found
nothing when we first looked down into a
microscope though
well we found more than we could ever
have guessed let's pretend that you and
I are among the earliest viewers of
microbes peering through a tiny piece of
crafted glass set into a brass plate and
through that lens we see a world that is
both entirely new and unknowable ancient
and as we look still in the earliest
days of charting this landscape of
cataloguing strange organisms that defy
or blur the classifications of plant or
animal we see among those myriad
mysterious creatures those bejeweled
diatoms and charming rotifers that make
up our initial glimpses of the micro
cosmos an ensemble of blue or green
trumpets large compared to many of the
other organisms we see their elongated
bodies adorned in rows and rows of
little hairs
it's that horned shape that will end up
identifying them not just by sight but
by name Stentor for the herald of the
Greek troops during the Trojan War whose
voice was said to carry with the
strength of 50 men of course our tools
and understanding of microbes have come
a long way since those first microscopic
investigations making it possible for us
to share this footage of our own
observations with you recently outside
Warsaw James found a small pond in the
middle of a forest that is filled with
microbes that pond has given us Morse
tenters to collect and fill
which means it's also provided us with
an excuse to check in again on our
favorite underappreciated organisms of
the micro cosmos after all
stent errs voice carried through
millennia but the legend of the
microbial Stentor seems more muted
across the centuries compared with some
of the more studied ciliates but modern
scientific tools are giving us a new
appreciation for centers but before we
get there we should note that it's not
like stent errs have never held any
fascination for scientists as we talked
about in our last Stentor focused
episode these single-celled organisms
have a complex body and uninformative
that regeneration process mirrors some
of the steps that drive the development
of animal embryos making spenders a
compelling object of study all the way
through the mid 20th century but
research is as much about the
practicalities as it is about exciting
questions and implications and for many
scientists centers were simply not the
right choice for their experiments they
were difficult to grow and in part
because of their tremendous size they
couldn't be used in the same
experimental setups that other organisms
were more amenable to and so other
ciliates that were easier to work with
like Paramecium went on to become more
popular modeled protozoa teaching us
through the lens of their own
single-celled eukaryotic bodies but
stunt errs weren't forgotten they were
just awaiting the right tools we here
work with the basics forest palms a
microscope and yes hundreds of hours
spent checking on our centres and we
still managed to find them in incredible
situations
this little ciliate pulls and pulls at
the center's membrane until it just
erupts you can see the bead-like nuclei
pouring out of the stent er along with
the food vacuoles and the rest of the
cytoplasm the inside of its body now
scattered around it and yet for all the
damage that is inflicted on this Center
it survives it's one thing to know that
stent errs are capable of this kind of
regeneration another thing altogether to
witness its survival in real time on our
slides
this regenerative capacity their shape
their color their size the fact that
they are single-celled organisms all of
those factors make it seem like we must
not have much in common with centers and
if we were just reliant on what we could
see we might still believe that but with
the ongoing development of new genetic
tools it's the thing we've discovered
that we share in common with centers and
that actually renders them distinct for
much of their brethren that has given
our trumpet friends a new role in the
study of the microscopic world when it
comes to genetics we often think of DNA
as a universal code this is the simple
story that were taught in biology class
three base pair sequences of DNA code
for amino acids to be added on to a
protein over and over until a gene
ending code is reached and the protein
is complete and those codes that decide
what amino acid is added on to the
protein well we're taught that that is a
universal thing it is not
there's what we call the standard code
the one that we and all multicellular
organisms use and then there are others
where letters change and punctuation
becomes words and most of these are
bacterial or mitochondrial code but
especially among eukaryotes ciliates are
noted genetic eccentrics due to their
tendency to take some of the sequences
that in our code signal the end of a
gene and interpret them as coding for
yet more amino acids to stack on to the
protein different ciliate lineages have
evolved their own versions of this
altered interpretation but there are
only a few ciliates
that have been thought to follow the
standard genetic code that the rest of
us do and stent errs are one of them and
with recent genetic techniques probing
the sequences of Stentor karolius that
strange conformity has now been
confirmed usually when we bring up
genetic studies of microbes on this
channel they raise questions about the
details of classification schemes in the
case of Stander's though they raise a
deeper question why do they resemble us
in this way and why don't the vast
majority of other ciliates if Stentor
karolius
follows the standard genetic code does
that mean that the original ciliate also
did and if so then does that mean that
the non-standard genetic codes exhibited
by so many ciliates now are not some
property inherent to that phylum but a
product of an evolutionary path that
started after the Stentor family began
to branch away of very
very long time ago now Ellucian is weird
and messy it is a knot that sometimes
seems to become more tangled the more we
try to unravel it and stent errs well
their confirmation that no matter how
simple something may seem whether it's
their own surprisingly complex
single-celled bodies or the supposed
universality of the genetic code it only
takes a few what's wise and house to
find yourself and meshed and a web of
questions that is not unlike the
marvelous mysteries first uncovered by
the original microbe hunters hundreds of
years ago their discoveries or
world-changing but so are ours we live
in a time of great knowing of great
uncovering but that has also helped us
realize how many mysteries we have yet
to solve thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us if you would
like to get a pin celebrating the
majesty of this peculiar organism we
have Stentor karolius pins available now
there's a link in the description and
also thank you so much to all of our
patrons on patreon who allow us to
continue these explorations and keep our
eyes out for more bizarre happenings in
our microscopes without people like this
the work we're doing here on journey to
the micro cosmos would not be possible
so if you're able to potentially join
them that would be amazing and thank you
to all of the people on this list if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James you can check out Jam
and germs on Instagram and if you want
to see more from us here at journey to
the micro cosmos you can find us at
youtube.com slash micro cosmos
you
[Music]